[Musique]
le sujet de cette présentation c'est une
afrique sans visa je m'appelle islam ce
que je suis malien mais je suis en
mauritanie
j'ai grandi à en guinée conakry j'ai
vécu au maroc j'ai vécu au bénin j'ai
vécu autour où j'ai fait mon lycée au
congo brazzaville
j'ai fait mes études à dakar au canada
aux états unis et donc pour moi je suis
autant malien qu'africain la première
fois que j'ai marché au mali j'avais 13
ans donc j'ai connu le reste de
l'afrique avant de connaître le mali et
pour moi c'est très important qu'on
s'identifie entend quatre africains en
marcus un panafricaniste de jamaïque a
dit en fait que les puissances
étrangères pour en libérer de
l'esclavagé de la colonisation mais
seuls nous africains pourront nous
libérer de l'esclavagé de la
colonisation mentale et l'a10 en 1937 et
aujourd'hui on est en 2010 est fui vers
le calcul aujourd'hui en tant
qu'africain on est toujours enfermé on
va dire dans cet esclavage mental qui
nous permet pas de ne pas avancer et
pour aller un peu plus dans le sujet
l'une des choses qui me conre regarde
justement l'émancipation du peuple
africain ont regardé différentes
différentes approches en termes de
politiques de développement
il ya une des approches pour ya
plusieurs approches en politique de
développement on parle beaucoup du
commerce régional de l'intégration
régionale en afrique pour permettre au
continent africain de se développer donc
maintenant l'intégration régionale en
afrique peut arriver de différentes
manières
dans un premier dans une première partie
il ya l'intégration régionale qui arrive
à travers le développement des
infrastructures
donc comment s'assurer par exemple qu'
on puisse mettre en place des autoroutes
qui nous permettront de conduire de
bamako jusqu'à dakar ou de bamako jusqu
à brazzaville et de bamako jusqu'à cape
town et de bamako jusqu'au caire devant
la cour jusqu'à alger de bamako jusqu à
nairobi
comment construire des infrastructures
qui nous permettront si on le veut
aujourd'hui comme ça se fait en europe
ou en asie ou aux états unis de juste
avoir de l'argent pour faire son plein
pendant une durée de quelques semaines
et de faire le tour de l'afrique
c'est ça la vision que actuellement les
acteurs du développement en comme la
banque africaine de développement les
acteurs bilatéraux et internationaux
mais malheureusement cette vision des
infrastructures va prendre énormément de
temps à se matérialiser
bien entendu parce que ça coûte
énormément d'argent pour pouvoir mettre
en place les infrastructures selon les
statistiques il faut plus de 50
milliards de dollars par année pour
investir dans les infrastructures de 50
milliards de dollars par année en
financement qui manque à l'afrique pour
les infrastructures chaque année donc ça
c'est sans compter tout l'argent qui
n'est qui est mal utilisée par nos
gouvernements afin de pouvoir atteindre
justement notre indépendance en termes
d'infrastructures et ceci a une histoire
on a été colonisée on été victime d'
esclavage à l'époque de l'esclavagé à
l'époque de la colonisation les routes
qu'elles ont été faites
elles ont été faites pour principalement
des places et on va dire des routes ont
été faites aux zones de matières
premières donc les mines d'or au port
donc les mines d'or du mali il ya des
routes qui t'amène jusqu'aux ports des
pays voisins
il exporte les mines de diamants et tous
les matières premières la manière dont
nos colonisateurs et nos esclavagistes
ont fait c'est juste
c'était ça leur priorité des hommes dans
des zones de matières premières au port
et à l'export donc avec cette cette
stratégie qu'ils avaient bien entendu
pour s'enrichir il n'y a aucune
opportunité pour nous africains
d'échanger entre nous donc il faut
totalement changé la donne pour qu'on
puisse arriver à ce point de changements
par rapport justement au développement
mais maintenant qu'on regarde le
développement il ya un point il ya une
politique de développement qui est
tellement simple à mettre en place mais
qui aura un impact géant sur le
développement c'est une afrique sans
visa
c'est un truc aussi simple que ça une
afrique sans visa un africain
moi en tant que malien je peux aller
dans l que n'importe quel pays en
afrique sans visa
c'est tout à fait normal mais c'est un
gros problème aujourd'hui selon les
statistiques
55% des africains ne peuvent pas se
déplacer pour aller dans un autre pays
sans avoir de visa sachant que
malheureusement il ya un grand nombre de
nos confrères européens occidentaux qui
eux ont des visas à l'arrivée et en fait
c'est tellement important c'est une
politique tellement simple qui est
d'ailleurs mise en place actuellement
mais on n'arrive pas à la mettre en
place à cause justement de cet esclavage
mental qui nous qui nous qui nous perd 6
actuellement
donc en fait les recherches et les
statistiques ont montré que bon bien
entendu on à la tong est la dernière
région à se développer
quand on regarde le cas de l'asie les 30
et les 40 dernières années il ya une
corrélation positive entre le
développement socio économique et
l'intégration et le commerce régional
on a vu que les pays asiatiques
de plus en plus et échanger entre eux et
ils arrêtaient d'échanger avec le reste
du monde de plus en plus et se sont
développées actuellement le commerce
régional en asie et à plus de 60 70 % et
dans l'union européenne le commerce
régional ont aussi et les échanges
régionaux sont appelés à 61 à plus de
70%
malheureusement nous aujourd'hui au mali
on est juste
à quatre tours en afrique on m'a dit on
et touche juste à 10 à 14%
la majorité de nos échanges c'est des
matières premières continue à produire
et continue à vendre au reste du monde
et les statistiques nous montrent que
c'est ça dont qu'est ce qui nous manque
un nous maliens et africains pour
pouvoir avoir une vision justement d'une
afrique sans visa mais aussi une afrique
où on peut échanger et aussi se
rencontrer et faire du business ensemble
sans avoir justement cette enclave âge
mental qu'il faut un visa pour aller
voir son pays voisins sachant que des
justement nos confrères de l'étranger
n'ont pas cette problématique
donc qu'est-ce qui bloque qu'est ce qui
bloque aujourd'hui en tant qu'africain
on a plus de similarités qu'on a de
différence on a plus de similarités
qu'on a de plus différence il ya
tellement à découvrir avec les pays
voisins que pour nous on est focalisé
sur aller en vacances en france
aller en vacances au canada étudier au
canada
étudier aux états unis aller en turquie
maintenant ou alors en chine au lieu de
se pencher et regarder toutes les
opportunités qui s'offrent à nous dans
les pays voisins qu'il ya une
corrélation directe est positive avec le
développement en 2015
l'union africaine a mis en place
l'agenda de 1063 et l'agenda 2,63 à
plusieurs on va dire et des eaux
une afrique intégrer une afrique où les
africains échangent entre eux en toute
liberté et puisse justement une afrique
où le développement est en place dans
l'agenda 2063 il ya justement toute une
partie sous l'afrique sans visa et
disent que en 2018 qui est censé être
l'année prochaine
les africains tous les africains pour
aller dans n'importe quel pays en
afrique sans visa aujourd'hui on n'est
qu'à 16 pays il n'y a que 16 pays en
afrique où nous maliens nous africains
pouvons nous rendent récemment c'est le
kenya qui a ouvert ses frontières aux
africains
et c'est vraiment une opportunité de
féliciter tous ces pays qui arrive
malheureusement le mali jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'a pas ouvert ses
frontières au reste des pays africains
en étant dans la baie dans la cedeao
on est ouvert à tous les ouest africains
on va dire mais le mali et d'autres pays
plus de à peu près une quarantaine de
pays n'ont pas ouvrir les frontières au
reste du monde dans ta question qu'on se
pose c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut pour
qu'on ouvre nos frontières on reste
l'afrique
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour que le mali
ouvre ses frontières au reste de
l'afrique qu'est ce qu'il faut pour que
ses hôtes des africains ou leurs
frontières au reste de l'afrique
bien entendu les sujets et les raisons
principales point d'entendre c'est la
migration
donc nous maliens on va peut-être si par
exemple d'autres pays comme l'afrique du
sud ou ces visas on va aller migrer en
afrique du sud y aura plus besoin de
visa il ya aussi tout ce qu'il s'agit du
terrorisme
on est dans un pays qui sort de crise on
est dans une zone aussi sahélienne qui
sort de crise donc à les problèmes de
terroristes qui sont mis de l'avant
il ya des problèmes aussi de trafic de
produits illégaux et à tout ce qui est
lié au terrorisme
mais selon moi moi je pense encore que
ces raisons c'est juste l'esclavagé
moderne
c'est juste l'esclavagé mental parce que
on a plus de similarités qu'on a de
différence et on a plus de gens avec de
bonnes intentions qu'on a deux gens avec
de mauvaises intentions et il faut pas
croire qu'on croit qu en ouvrant new
frontier ou que tous les pays africains
ou de leurs frontières vont mener
justement à un chaos potentiel donc ça
c'est l'une des raisons potentielles
comment on peut se fixer comme objectif
justement nous aujourd'hui au mali mais
les autres pays d'afrique en 2018 de
parler justement à nos ânes ou anneau
couvert anneau couvert anneaux à nos
ministres à nous à notre gouvernement et
leur demander pour 2018 d'ouvrir les
frontières au mali au reste de l'afrique
on est content de voir justement des
politiques dans la salle on aimerait que
justement le mali soit ouvert au reste
de l'afrique en un pays qui sort de
crise le nord n'est pas stable mais tout
ça c'est qu'une classique un esclavage
mental
donc on va passer justement au deuxième
point mais comment imaginer justement
cette afrique sans visa comment imaginer
cette intrigue sans visa à quoi va
ressembler aujourd'hui je suis là et je
peux vous dire que des circonstances ont
fait que
on m'a offert un joli bout et j'avais
quelque chose j'avais besoin de porter
un habit pour venir me rendre à cet
événement et j'ai dû porter un bout mais
je seul sait que je ne suis pas fier de
la vie que je porte aujourd'hui il est
produit en europe et il est revenu une
en nous le ramène en afrique et on nous
le vend à un prix trois fois plus cher
donc je suis là en train de vous prenez
une afrique sans visa dans un pays
producteur de coton mais on n'arrive pas
à développer justement des industries
qui vont nous permettre de faire ça et
c'est très simple en fait c'est très
simple on parle d'une afrique sans visa
le thème d'aujourd'hui c'est ouvrir
l'afrique et le sujet que je dois
présenter
c'est juste une seule idée mais je
voudrais vous introduire aujourd'hui
aussi qu'il faut qu'on ferme l'afrique
au reste du monde
il faut qu'on ferme l'afrique au reste
du monde il faut que les africains n'ont
plus accès à d'autres pays que des pays
africains la chine s'est fermée pendant
400 ans du 15e siècle au 19e siècle
les chinois ont dit on ne va faire plus
de business avec plus aucun pays
on fait du business entre nous chinois
si tu as besoin
dabi tu vas dans la province voisine tu
prends ton nabila bah si tu as besoin de
riz tu vas dans l'état d'un côté tu
prends ton riz là bas s'il ya besoin de
boire du vin à hong kong où tu prends en
bois parce que en tant que l'économie
africaine
on est tellement vulnérable à cause des
raisons que vous le savez qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre opportunité pour nous de se
développer que de fermer l'afrique au
reste du monde
bien entendu c'est une vision bien
entendu c'est une idéologie qui va
prendre plusieurs heures
on va dire décennies avant d'être mise
en place
mais ça doit se mettre de manière on va
dire
elle doit se présenter de manière
progressive
sssa l'instauration des quotas
aujourd'hui si on dit au mali qu'on n'en
portera au lieu d'importer plus de 100 %
de nos besoins en textile on importe 80
% de nos besoins textile pour 2018 je
vous dis bien que des entrepreneurs vont
pouvoir aller sur les zones ou envoi du
content pour pouvoir transformer 2 se
comptant en habits que nous on pourra
apporter aujourd'hui et que moi je
pourrais porter justement pour un
prochain événement comme ça sans me
sentir gêné parce que là actuellement je
représente pas justement ce que je dis
malheureusement non c'est vraiment
essayer de voir comment non seulement
d'une première partie il faut qu'on se
batte en tant qu'africaine pour ouvrir
justement l'afrique aux africains parce
que c'est curieux c'est qu'un esclavage
mental parce que nos contenus que nous
contrôlons nos confrères occidentaux ils
ont cette opportunité et nous on ne sait
pas quel type d'occidentaux viennent en
afrique on s'en fout du moment qui la
résidente aux hivers dans l'afrique
ça peut être quelqu'un qui a fait 15 ans
en prison dix ans en prison et s'il ya
des exemples comme ça tous les jours
alors qu'il faut qu'on passe à cette
idéologie et pour monter dans une
idéologie maintenant de fermer l'afrique
aux africains il faut qu'on pense
maintenant comment nous ici dans la
salle et nous en afrique qu'on décide
les prochaines vacances
je n'irai pas en france les prochaines
vacances j'irai en tanzanie les
prochaines vacances gérée au rwanda pour
pour les études de mes enfants au lieu
de les envoyer aux états unis pour des
cours d'anglais je les enverrais en
afrique du sud
j enverrai à cape town où je les
enverrais aux canards il faut qu'on
puisse essayer de penser de plus en plus
comment consommer africain produire
africains et d'échangés entre n'ont pour
le moment les infrastructures vont
arriver on est patient d'ici une
cinquantaine d'années moi je meurs si je
suis bien toujours en vie je me vois
très bien prendre une voiture et être en
voiture ou en train jusqu'en afrique du
sud jusqu'au caire sans visa et une
charles ainsi que je le veux cette
vision va se matérialiser
mais pour que cette vision se
matérialisent faut que nous mêmes
en plus savoir vivre entre nous
africains si on ne sait pas de quoi est
fait notre pays voisins si demain les
infrastructures sont là on aura toujours
cette idée du congolais qui aime juste
faire la fête ou qui aiment bien
s'habiller mais on ne sait pas justement
quelles sont quel similarités on a avec
le peuple congolais qui sont des
similarités plus plein de grandes et
plus nombreuses qu'on a avec le reste du
monde donc on résumer en fait
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous encourager
tout un chacun à penser à être
activistes pour pousser une afrique sans
visa pour pousser pour 2018 un mali sans
visa pour le reste des africains et pour
inspirer justement le reste des pays
sahéliens mais au reste de l'afrique
allez si justement le bénin ya quelques
mois a décidé d'ouvrir ses frontières
sur le style kenya qui est un pays aussi
fier a ouvert ses frontières à tous les
africains c'est que nous on peut le
faire je vous remercie et j'espère que
je le prends pour avoir ainsi